Taste bugs. They come into the mic, talking about the food.
They hate talking about the food they like to, fool's gonna fake it.
Only one food, 10 rate taste buds, man. Didn't come into them.
I come shock and say, Hey.
Welcome to taste buds. The podcast about food. We fight it out. We Duke it out.
We argue food. My name's Joe. Hey, I'm Sal. We got a good one for you today. Oh,
we got to go on for you to taste buddies. We have,
we have sort of traipsed into breakfast territory in the past.
Uh, not, not, I guess, less frequently than some of the other meals, but, uh,
we today are daring to set foot in the arena of cereal.
Breakfast, cereal. Uh.
And we got two good ones that are going to face off here.
A classic.
Do you want to get something out of the way that we both think this is? Uh,
sometimes we have, you know, we also, we also bond over.
Good point. Yeah. Yeah.
We think the best breakfast cereal ever is captain crunch with crunch berries at
the moment. Uh, you know, yeah.
But they're always a competitor for me. And there's one that I love.
One of my favorite shows that I love that has recently changed their formula
formula or, or flavor that has taken a hit for me, but in its best form,
I put it up there and it's never anyone's favorite, right. Posts alphabets.
But I could never put that up against a popular cereal.
I, you know, man, I had alphabets once as a kid or twice, maybe I remember it,
it just tasting like, it was like it was missing. It was like lucky charms,
except there was no.
Marshmallows. That's right. It's a little different, but it's right.
And sometimes I think the marshmallows are a bit too much,
but they did venture in, uh, alphabets was a blue box.
Alpha-beta marshmallows was a purple box and it was just as popular if not more
popular. I don't know if they still make the, the alphabets with marshmallows.
Okay. But, uh,
but that's not who I'm going to put up against because I know for a fact I'm
going to lose that one by a landslide. And it just, I kind of want,
I could argue it, believe me, but, but,
but I'd rather do something that I think is a little bit of a closer.
I'm also a huge fan, big surprise of chips, hoist cereal,
which I did bring into the fall.
This company has gotten you by, by the, the, the ball, the balls.
That's what you want to call them.
Be arguing on behalf of an American classic.
And I don't like chocolate cereal, by the way. I don't understand.
I want to say, I don't want to wake up and eat sweets. Like, I mean, well,
I guess I should, I don't want to eat up any chocolate. It's weird to me.
I don't, I don't want chocolate. The moment I wake up, I don't want chocolate.
I don't want chocolate cocoa pebbles. I do not.
You don't like chips. Uh Armena uh, cookie crisp.
Well, when I said I didn't like chocolate cereal,
I didn't mean besides these 10.
I know I'm just getting you ready.
Buddy. I don't like, um,
I hate pancake or waffle maple syrup cereal,
or I don't like when they just load all like this,
it's like supposed to taste like else. Do.
You like chocolate chip pancakes?
Oh, you sure don't mind. Really? Yeah.
But there's something about those that I don't know.
I don't feel it as chocolate per se. Blueberry. I'll take first.
But my point is in serial form,
I don't want it to be chomping on some processed chocolate.
I hate chocolate chip banks. I hate chocolate chip pancakes. There's too much.
It's too much. Oh my God. What?
Well you just see, just see one. This is where you curb it. No, no, no, no.
But those first few bites forget about it. They believe.
I like it. I like it because you can't.
Your bees, aren't blown off first three bites of a, of a chocolate chip cookie.
Nope. And I'll tell you why. And it's the same reason.
I'm not crazy about blueberry pancakes either.
Now I'll take a blueberry pancake over chocolate. And once in a while,
I'll think I want a blueberry pancake and then I'll regret it.
I never want a chocolate pancake. Uh, now.
Here's why listen to another episode, just pouring.
That syrup onto it. It's tough.
Who much, man? It's dif it's two different kinds of sweets.
I don't know why I agree. I don't even put syrup onto it.
I pour my syrup on the side and I control my, uh,
my syrup proportions, but I dip into the syrup. Sometimes I don't even do that.
You know what I do because that's too much, you know what I do?
Sometimes I place my fork into the syrup. I lifted out.
I let it drip off so that there's just a light coating on the four prongs.
And then I spear the pancake and I eat it with as minimal maple syrup as
possible. I get to touch a flavor, but I hate dousing it in and a lot of syrup.
Okay. So if I've enlightened you in any way, please take that.
I still don't want to eat chocolate chip pancakes. Um.
It's our, I think a waffle is better than a pancake anyway.
I mean, what do you do with this? I mean, it's ridiculous.
The international house of waffles. Yeah. That's a, that's a popular choice.
That's what you should stand behind. Stand behind. I hop,
they're known for quality. There's nothing. One sidewalk.
I Perkins, you know, Derrick accessible.
They're very accessible. Like,
like it's like there is assessable establishments that I don't think are known
for high quality, fresh ingredients. You know, if I, if I'm going to,
I can name,
I can name a hundred other places that will give me a better pancake than I hop
a hundred.
Change, the.
Major change. But my point is it's chained food.
Chain food, correct? Yeah. You know,
any other chains is putting five shirts out on the table. Perkins, Perkins,
get the outta here.
I mean, I don't get any credit for answering correctly.
Perkins does not put Perkins is the, I hop of Perkins.
Perkins is the iHub of IOP like Perkins. I'm not going to say they don't.
What am I trying to say? Perkins is the iHub of non IHOPs IHOPs.
Listen, I've, I'll eat simple.
I'll eat at Perkins,
but you're you put an apples and oranges together here at Perkins is not.
Perkins is fine.
It's identical menus. Dennis.
Dennis is putting out SERPs scissors, like nobody's busy or not. Nobody's busy.
They do not have that syrup bar on the table. Like I hopped up.
I don't know, get me wrong. See what I say? I don't know about it. But, um,
but I do feel that Denny's Perkins and I hop are cut from the same cloth.
And so, and I do know that they,
I think they might have multiple don't get me wrong. No,
one's going to put the stamp on a pancake,
like the chain of international house of pancakes, less sweet, less.
We call out when they change their names to international house of that was a
joke burgers.
It was a publicity joke. Oh, it did. Well, it did. You're talking about it.
That's the point I thought they changed. That's what everybody thought.
And they didn't. So they are.
I mean, this is brand confusion. No.
They sit there. They did it.
It was a thing to just let you know that we have burgers now.
And it was a big publicity stock.
I thought they only had burgers now and not pancakes.
And I've never gone in one again. Cause I could get a burger. So you haven't.
Notice the signs are changed back to I hop. They.
Changed all the signs. Yes. That was the last bit. I guarantee you,
someone got fired for that. I guarantee it works like a charm.
It was a [inaudible].
It wasn't a full pot charm.
That was, that was taken, you know, decades of loyal, uh, of,
uh, of Goodwill and, and being like, we, we, we, we turn our,
let me get back to why blind-eye yeah.
The pancakes flavored pancake is a bad thing. This isn't even the episode.
It's not, but we're going to talk about it now. Let me get back to why,
why don't we say it? Why don't we save that? Because you know what,
that's what I thought.
And then you had to put your little jab in that you think the wildfire is better
than the pancake and you knew what you were doing when you did that.
I'll change.
To waffle pancake right now. Don't tell me what a good time.
Change it to waffle pancakes.
Are you serious as you opened up a can of worms?
Because I also believe.
That a good episode could be pancake versus nah, you're right. Here's the thing.
You opened up a pancake and waffle the proper adversary to face off here
or,
or do we pull back a little and pancake known as the King of breakfast food?
Really? Unless you're in Bavaria, does pancake go up against like a bacon, egg,
and cheese? We're doing a two-parter because it's like the breakfast type thing.
It very different.
Whereas pancake is more popular than a waffle and they also are kind of similar.
I think waffles have a good shot and I'll take in pancakes all day long now.
So we should do,
we should ask them if they want to see pancake Russ waffle or pancake versus
Beck, bacon, egg, and cheese, we should ask them that at least you.
Can't put a pancake versus a bacon, egg, and.
Cheese, but then you're arguing. What's a better breakfast food.
That's breakfast food.
But you, because it's like are, are arguing Apple juice versus orange juice.
What we did pancakes and waffles are the adversaries. George Carlin had a joke.
I have a message here from the international house of pancakes.
And it says waffles. That was like, like that. There they are.
The face off foods.
Pancakes or waffles. I'm sure they do nothing if you need to.
But since I don't know, please give me the actual facts. And I'd like to say,
we should not only do pancakes versus waffles right now because you stirred it
up.
You started something and you know what you did and don't roll your eyes because
you knew what you were doing. Cause we go to bat for my cereal. So was I.
You brought up pancakes.
Being not as you just change it, change it, change it, right? I mean,
he brought it up. Folks. You almost saw golden Grahams versus fruit loop.
We'll do it another time it's coming back. It's coming back,
but you let us down a road.
And we talked last night on the phone about what are we doing tomorrow?
And we brought up waffles versus pancakes and you go I'm waffles all the way.
And I go, dude, I'm pancakes all the way. So.
I, you know, here we are is a big one.
Then if you want to change it on the fly and I guess check your local listings
for fruit loops for scolding grants.
But it's not going anywhere better.
Breakfast is how I'm titling it. What gets put first better.
Food, pancakes, waffles or pancakes. Second.
Cause you think pancakes was going to win. I think waffles could win.
I don't agree with it, but I do think it could win.
The fans are seeing a little behind the scenes right now.
And I liked that for them.
Pancakes is more popular in G in general. I like to put,
Oh, I won't even give anything away. We got
to people here in the logic and then thinking that you're going to YouTube.
People, very adversarial right out of the gate.
You taste buds launch that poll, watch that poll and let's just get into it,
dude. All right. Let's just get into it because this is already getting hot. I,
you know, we had two real hot episodes there already and I was like, we don't,
I don't know if we've got a lot left in the tank. I'm like,
we've got a lot left in the tank. Oh, I got to, I got left in and by the way,
pancakes or waffles, which one do you see?
This is part one of a two-part on breakfast battles. Okay. Mikey,
make a note of that. The breakfast battles. Okay. This is part one.
Part two is the next episode. It's bacon versus sausage. And then I got to get,
we got to do cereal. We could do a whole breakfast month this month.
Okay. All right. So, so, so.
You just want to know, and then you always roll your eyes at me,
but what am I ever listing first put.
Waffles first. Since you think the pancakes is going to.
Win. I also want your opinion. I don't want to just hold those.
If I told you my opinion,
three times now I've said put pancake executive because you think it's going to
win. I think waffles.
Just agree what I'm saying for the sake of it.
I'm not want to make sure you get a fair shake at what you're paying.
And I get a little bit, can you give me.
A little more credit than that please? You know, when people say.
Together, no one ever goes waffles and pancakes.
People always say pancakes and waffles. So put pancake second. And the re yeah,
but uh, yeah, I can I'll put it. This is going to get regional too.
Yeah. Cause you got, I hop everywhere.
I need my Belgian people to a Belgian Belgian origin launched
better breakfast, food, waffles, pancakes. Boom.
All right. We're in South. So let me say why now that the clock is running. Now,
let me say why. I think this is so regional.
It's not just about America and Belgium and these other places
it's within America.
There is an internal struggle between these two foods because you do have I hop,
which is a nationwide restaurant, but you also have waffle house now,
waffle house.
Oh man, I liked that you brought waffle house into this.
Nationally is nationally as accessible because it's not as spread around,
but people that like waffle house will live and die on the sword of waffle
house.
So you're going to get a lot of support. This is nothing against waffle house,
but I didn't grow up around waffle houses.
And I've only been to them a few times. And uh,
I don't want to attach my waffle to the waffle house chain.
You could attach your pancake to whatever chain you want.
It's not attaching it to.
Anything. I'm just saying, it shows you the love for the food.
I don't know enough about waffle house.
They make a hell of a waffle it's called waffle.
House. I've never had a waffle at a waffle house. Good.
But my point is arguing love out there, waffle and every way that you want it.
I love the, you know what I, as a kid, when my mom made, um,
and Jamaima blueberry waffles was my favorite breakfast.
I liked them over Eggos. I liked my waffles square, not round, but then again.
Yeah.
I'll take it. It goes, I'll take it. It goes as well.
But my point is is that I love a delicious waffle in the house,
but then I love a delicious waffle at a diner and how it's bigger.
And the, the, uh, what do you call them? What should we go? The nooks,
the crevices, the compartments, the divots. What do you want to call them?
I call them the holes personally. Oh, they're not holes. Are they now? Well,
that's what I call them. I mean, it's not like a swished.
It means like you asked me what I call them. I can tell you when to call them.
Okay, well, this is what, okay. So first of all, this is,
this is what general consensus is.
How many people prefer waffles or pancakes in general?
47% of people prefer pancakes to waffles. Does that mean 53 is waffles,
but among those for whom belly aches are a bigger problem than headaches.
59% of people. I don't understand what's going on here.
They're saying what kind of a poll was that? Pancakes or whales?
Waffles. They've been around for some time. At least since the 19, sorry.
The 14th.
Thirties.
I'm competing with a dish that has been around 690
years. The first wildfire who's 590 years.
First waffle iron was patented.
In 1869.
Oh my God. So 400, 439 years later,
incomes the waffle pancakes adversary.
That should say a lot about the waffle and what it's done.
The nation stages to now.
The only waffle eat, the only elite is a frozen waffle.
That's it?
You don't want a freshly made waffle out of a waffle line.
I get local holiday Inn. No.
Like at a continental breakfast, you don't, you don't want to go to,
you don't want to go to a diner.
I can't go New York diner and order a Belgian waffle.
Belgian waffle. Don't get me. Hold on.
I'm getting you don't want to get to Belgium. Hold on.
In between some nice ice cream shrimp, some fresh whipped cream.
Or ice cream. No, not at all. You haven't heard of that.
Waffle, but I treat them.
Disgust in my face. I've heard of it. I don't like it. Uh.
The only waffle you'll eat is a frozen store-bought waffle.
And you're going to argue that the pancake is better than the waffle in its
fullest form. I've eaten.
In the other kinds. And I don't like it. I don't like the flavor of it.
I like the flavor of a frozen waffle.
I find that other waffles as you call them homemade, uh,
don't have the same flavor.
They usually have a much sweeter or nuttier flavor that I don't care for.
I liked the flavor of a frozen waffle.
I could crush a box of Eggos easily, easily in one sitting.
I could do it. If, if, if, if I, if I was, if I was in the mood.
But you're in a, you're in good company, but.
I can't tell you.
I've never once stopped at that waffle iron at the ho at the holiday and not
once on a continental breakfast.
That's wild because even the process, again, I'll kind of harken back.
I love the overall experience of the food. That's how I judge it. Right?
I love the waffle iron.
I love getting the batter and watching it fill up in the different holes until
it fills it up. And then you push the RN down it sizzles,
and then there's a flip involved and you get them golden Brown.
And what happens with a waffle is you get crispy and doughy. You get,
when you spread the, um, the syrup and the butter, you get pockets.
Some have more than others. You get a different taste experience.
I'm buying into a waffle, I'm getting something real crisp on the outside.
Then all of a sudden it's getting Shulie and fluffy and inside,
and I'm getting the creaminess of the butter and the maple syrup.
It's multiple textures combining for a flavor experience in my mouth that
a pancake doesn't do. A pancake is light and fluffy,
but the consistency is the same.
And a lot of pancakes aren't made the right way.
And it just like ends up being this real mushy maple syrup sponge.
Whereas the crispiness of the waffle holds the maple syrup from penetrating
through to the inside dough. And then when you bite it,
you're still getting them in a layer of Sera, crisp dough.
And not this just sponge disk in your mouth of pancakes.
I will say this, I cannot, I cannot take credit, uh,
or responsibility for the people that don't know how to make the pancake
properly. That's their problem. But when a pancake is made properly,
it should have the consistency of moist Duncan Hines cake,
basically. That's where you're at, except it's warm. I love it. In his greatest,
in his.
Greatest state. I'm talking, telling you that the pancake is flush.
Be it should be thin. It should never be crispier crunchy on the outside.
It should be soft and spongy to the touch and it should be thin.
And when you cut a pancake up, may properly like that into,
into little wedges and I cut it all up and then I butter it.
So I get the butter all EV everywhere.
And then I pour syrup on the side and I poke and I dip and that's how I eat.
And it is.
I'm glad that's how you eat it, but why is it better than the waffle? Because.
Cause it's just a, it's just a more w in my opinion.
It's a more wonderful, they sell frozen pancakes. Yes. Well,
they are not popular are. And I wonder why. Well, I mean,
but then you don't hear people getting frozen pancakes.
I can hear people getting frozen waffles, but my dad.
Home visiting, for instance,
perhaps this Christmas he'll make me pancakes grease in the morning.
He'll make me pancakes in the morning.
He'll make all of us pancakes in the morning.
But my point is is there's nothing like it. There's nothing like it.
There's pancakes or late night food.
Something very, very like it. It's called the waffle.
And it's what we're debating.
And it's why you said pancakes should go against waffle because it's,
it's rightful adversary because it's so close together.
Then bacon is so the waffle goes against it.
The waffles been around for hundred and 40 years less.
And is its contemporary competitor. It's done a lot.
You have a food that was invented in the 14 hundreds at ancient Greece to
pancake.
The other reason I like the pancake,
you can make it in different ways with different ingredients.
Like if you're on a low carb thing,
I have a recipe where you can make pancakes out of bananas and almond flour and
whatever. And I've never been able to do it in a waffle. Have you tried? No.
Have you?
Nope. Have you ever asked anyone else if they've done it? No.
I've just made the assumption. It sounds like the typical Joe DeRosa argument,
but show me, show me.
Uh, Mike, look up. Uh.
I look at those two. Can you just go back a second?
If you could throw those photos out,
look at the waffles on the left of the pancakes are both look delicious again.
I'm not, I don't hate pancakes, but if I had to choose,
I'm choosing a waffle every time.
Look at how those waffles it had just so much more appealing to me.
You got the stack of pancakes, this smashing each other together.
The same exact thing. You dumped a syrup on the top.
If you not putting in the work to lift every flapjack or every pancake and put
butter on everything and syrup on everything, then you just get in a big man.
The waffle it's like a leaning tower of deliciousness. There's just,
they decided to put fruit. Does that even beep on it?
They put a little fruit on it.
They put a little syrup on it and it's crispy golden. You're comparing.
Picture versus one picture that I've seen tiny cakes.
I've seen pancakes prepared like that with fruit and whipped cream.
Okay. You're right. I'm comparing two pictures, but I wouldn't say, look,
I don't care for it. Honestly. I don't get the texture.
You're just eating a pile of sponges when you're, when you're eating a pancake.
That's the texture pancake. That's doesn't even sound good to me. Oh,
in waffle sounds good. Waffle sounds intriguing. It sounds waffle.
Waffle. What does that,
it sounds like something that comes out of your colon is what it sounds like.
It doesn't sound right. It sounds gross. It sounds.
They have waffle cones, right? You don't have a pancake cone. [inaudible].
Do you have a pancake cake ice cream sandwich?
You know what else? I hate it.
I hate a waffle ice cream sandwich and you can actually hold the ice cream.
What else I've had? That always sounds like a great idea.
And then it sucks a waffle sandwich. I've gone to restaurants where it's like,
we put two, we put a piece of fried chicken in between slices, a waffle my God,
Oh my God. You're doing yourself a disservice.
I'd never heard of the waffle sandwich,
but I almost forgot that you could put fried chicken with waffles for one of the
greatest meals that anyone's ever heard of in your entire life.
I wasn't even going to bring it up and you go ahead and bring up waffles and
fried chicken. You're not doing yourself a disservice.
You can't have a fried chicken so much between a bunch of soft pancakes.
You don't think you could have some, I mean, nobody does it, but you don't.
I mean, I think it will be adjacent, but there's a reason why the time.
Dominating dish and the original dish, and the only dish you really see is,
is as.
Look at me, look at that pancakes. Just Google. I mean the pancake sandwich,
everything from Roscoe's go away. By the way, by the way.
Two, up on your high horse there, who's heard of a pancake sandwich.
I'm sorry. A crepe, a crate, a crepe is not a pancake.
It's defined.
As being a part of the pancake is a pancake. A crepe is a crepe. I mean,
crepe is you weren't. You were about to argue that that.
By extension you could tell me a crepe is better than.
A waffle fluffy Swedish pancakes. But buddy, when you go,
let me ask you a question. Crepes are talking about, we know the CLIA.
Crepe is a pancake that's been thinned out.
So can we go to every single episode ever that he's done, where he says,
you cannot adjust. You cannot leave all.
You got to lean on the fact that you have to serve at a different way.
I'm showing you another.
So you contradict yourself and I'm saying it's another version of the paler
about the version of the pancake called the crepe. Cause that's a crepe.
When I go get a crate, I get a crepe. When I want a crepe back on a crepe.
When I want to Mike, what? We're arguing here. When you do the edit,
I want it here. Arguing. I want to hear that is thin.
It doesn't taste the same and it's not the same concept of what's so never broke
case extraordinarily the shame. Oh,
you just never eat it with syrup and butter. Are you ordering crepe versus
talking about the traditional pancake, Joe?
You've never you can't co-op the crepe. And now make the crates at a tag team.
So two on one. So let me get this straight on the record.
Let me get this straight. You are allowed.
Let me get this straight and I'll tell you
[inaudible] crepe Cray.
It's going to be 99 to 1% or point counter point.
So let me get this straight. You can do frozen waffle versus awful.
Hold on. You can do frozen wild food pancake. And you brought up Belgian waffle.
That's a completely different version of the wall.
The size it's the same steno. The crepe is the same thing.
The creep is not. If I, if you close your eyes,
I put a crepe in your mouth and I go, hi, you like my pancakes? You're gonna go.
This ain't a pancake. It's a crepe. No, that's what you gotta do.
And you're gonna say highlights. That's how your voice is going to come. Good.
I know you. I would say there's a thin pancake. Oh, you're dumped there. Winded.
Colton pancakes says
I'm going to go to a little cafe and go,
can I have an espresso and a little pancake please?
The crepe crepe. When your affects come up on the internet,
their facts are when mine come up, you go, they don't count.
Why are waffles better? Let's go back. Let's just go.
Let's just see popular convention. Answer my question about the crape.
Why wouldn't you see the factual information?
A crepe is part of the pancake family is considered a thin pancake.
Does that not count as fact as it? You so,
so what you're,
what you're telling me right now is you're contending that creeps can be as
equal a part of this argument versus waffles. Absolutely. Oh my God.
When you're talking about bringing change the rules, it's not a rule change.
We can't get anywhere. Fin pancakes. And you use them to put away.
When I say the word pancake does a crepe come to mind? No. Oh, Joe,
please. It did. Saxo say I'm starving. I want to get some pancakes.
What w what are you saying? And what do I think you're getting okay, fine. If I,
if I'm at a local cafe and I say, Oh, I'm going to get a crepe and a coffee.
Okay. Am I getting her a stack of silver dollar pancakes? You know,
have you ever gone to a crepe restaurant?
People eat them with butter and syrup like pancakes.
They believe that if you want to order, if you want to fight crepe first,
while you want to go to creepers, while I go, I'll delete. I'll delete.
I'll do Creek Creek. I'll leave it. I'll do it right now.
I'll do something that's unprecedented.
I'll do crepe versus waffle right now and give you
a 10%. I'll give you, I'll give you a tender, wave it around.
I will give you a 10% handicap. I'll go. No, you know what?
I'll give you a 20% handicap. Give me a,
I will give you a 20% handicap on creepers waffle. Stop with the question. Okay?
Then you can't count Belgium waffles. Then,
then you can't count Belgium because that's a vaguer. Well,
let's just say for the sake of this versus roll your eyes at it.
If little pancakes don't count giant waffles don't count. That's it.
But the creep is not the same as the pant is it just said on the screen,
it's a thin pancake. It's just said it's in theory. Oh my God, Mike,
please go to the crepes Wikipedia page. It says it right there.
It's made on a cast iron griddle. It's a pancake.
That's been thinned out and stuffed,
but thinner waffle is still cold and waffle. Oh,
excuse me. Can you beat that? Oh my God.
Grape is also the French name for a pancake. Alright, well,
I don't go a waffle something else. Frigid means pancake,
but you're not battling the preparation of a crepe battling the classic.
You know what he does when he wants me, I put.
It in classic ice cream sandwich, traditional ice cream.
Sandwich, original. Blah-blah-blah when he doesn't want me to,
he just puts pancake. And now traditional pancake is out the window.
If I would have wrote traditional pancake versus traditional waffle,
would that make you happier? Well, guess what I mean?
I guess when I say traditional waffle people saying, put a diner Belgian,
WAFs just to prove my point, Mike, just to prove my point and show them.
I'm a fair sport. More than fair. Wait, wait. Don't don't wait, wait, wait.
Don't go off yet. Let me read this. Okay.
Mike crepes are thinner in larger than an English pancake.
They usually have Richard ingredients.
Food and sugar and or cream, and are only cooked on one side. Okay? Okay. So, so
I'm trying to do something to your benefit. Hold on.
You could argue that it's prepared differently. So technically doesn't count.
I want you to show me now how a Belgian Warren.
Is prepared. Same as irregular waffle. It's just bigger. It's the same thing.
When I say traditional waffle people think, Oh, the waffle I get at the diner,
that's a Belgian waffles.
Waffles are thicker and often larger because they're made in a waffle iron that
is deeper Gritch to build your waffles.
Also made a little differently than regular waffles.
Justin, with a li li leavening agent or egg whites use to make the
batter light and fluffy. It doesn't count. It's out.
My point being is that a Belgian.
Waffle is called a waffle. You don't.
I mean, that's ridiculous.
Sal that's ridiculous called something different things saying it's like saying,
uh, uh, uh, a cabasa is in part of the sausage family.
Cause it's called a cabasa. I mean, that's crazy.
Right? Hold on. If I come back to that diner and I go and you go, Hey,
what'd you do? And I got, I went to the dining to go what'd you eat? And I go,
I eat a waffle. Right? You know what I'm talking about? Yeah. Okay. That,
that ate a waffle.
And I, you know what I said, you know what I say? Ready?
You want me to say let's do it ready? Hey sir. Where, where are you just now?
I know I got one. No, no, no, no, no, no. I had another one. Okay.
The wait to do it though. I'm ready. Okay. Okay. Ready? So we're worried.
How was that? My local diner. What'd you Jeff today? Yeah. I had a, a waffle,
just one. Cause they're tiny. Just one waffle. Now the dynam off was a pig. Oh,
you had a Belgian waffle. It's different. Well, it's a waffle. Yeah,
but it's different. Hold on, Joe. I just got back from the diner and boy,
my stuffed. Right. But I took her to go container. It's not clear.
It's it's plastic. You can't see what's in it. Okay. I had pancakes. Right?
You want them open it up? Boom. It's for crepes. What do you say to me?
You say, I thought you said pancakes. Grape. That's what you would say.
You would not open it. Go. Jeez. Delicious tea.
People understand you.
Jealous saw you are saying is, is Belgium waffle.
Hold on. Hold. Crepe does. Hold on, babe. Hold on. Ready, Joe.
How are you this morning? Great. Guess where? I just came from the crepe place.
The diner. Oh great. You know what? I had crepes. I had waffles. Oh good.
I actually have extra waffles here. Cause I was so hungry here. Open it.
When you open it, are you going to go? This is not a waffle. No,
you're going to go. Oh. I don't know what I'm looking at. An invisible thing.
A Belgian waffle a Belgian. Whenever I go. And I'm like, no, no, no, no, no, no.
That's not my point. That's not my point.
I have a to go container. It's it's it's opaque.
You can't see through it. Is that what it's called? Yes.
You can't see through it. I say, Joe, you say, what'd you eat today?
I said I had waffles. I, there was so great. I had so many. I took some home.
Would you like some? You say yes. I hand you it.
You open the to go container that you can't see inside until that moment when
you open it, your brain will confirm. Oh yeah,
those are the waffles he was talking about. And then you will eat the waffles.
You will not go. This is not a waffle. Flip it. Reverse it, smack it down.
[inaudible] I'll tell you exactly how I'll tell you right now. I had a
[inaudible] pancakes here,
me to crave Tacome pancakes and I'll show you exactly how I had a stack of
pancakes. You open it up. It's two crepes in that you would go,
Hey pig. You said pantry. I would go now. You know what I would do? Show me,
show me. Good morning, Joe. Good morning. Hand me the paper.
I want to start off on a nice, we went to diner,
South accusing me of being an alibi.
He said good morning. And my in my, in my Jefferson breakfast, yay.
Breakfast will come to you. Would you have pancakes?
A lot of them so many I can't eat anymore. That's weird because they're so tiny.
You want some of my patients? This is my pancakes. That's weird, Mike.
It's weird that he calls them pancakes. Traditionally,
people say these are crepes, but technically they are pancakes now. Oh,
good job. Your argument on a technicality.
His whole argument based on a technicality knowledge. If crepe,
stoke camped in Belgium waffles.
So cause Belgian waffles are also made differently. Hearing what you're saying.
And I'm counter pointing by saying,
if I told you I went to the diner and had a waffle of my [inaudible] container,
I just had a stroke and you opened it. No, it was a Belgium waffle.
You would go as advertised. If I did the same thing,
you'd have to remark out loud. You would have to remark that. Oh,
these are crepes. I guess it's like a pancake,
but I thought you meant the other thing. Here's not basing my argument on that.
Okay. I think it's stupid.
It's like saying this. It's like saying this.
I feel [inaudible]. I feel,
let me say my thing before you say irrational.
You're just going to say it. Let me say my thing. It's like saying salsa.
Isn't a dip because it's called salsa and you go. Yeah,
because that's just what call it.
From where it comes from. It's a dance,
a little more of a blurred line and a little more of a blurred line.
It is in the dead. Something into salsa. Yes.
I don't necessarily syrup on crave for Christ sakes. You commie bastard.
You don't. Yes.
You do get some type of a straw Berry terms. You do.
You would get hazelnut and banana. Sometimes I get ham.
And cheese in the middle of the things. You.
Know what? I never get chocolate chips or blueberries. If you saw pimps face.
When you just said that again, you just pulled,
you pulled the rug out from your own two silly feet
because nobody eats a pancake with ham and cheese sandwich.
There was exhibit a,
there was a pancake breakfast sandwich earlier that I tried to point out to you,
but you, because you're so good at multitasking.
You didn't notice it because your eyes were
looking at you can Google. Uh, you can go.
You can Google red wing boot in between two pancakes.
I love and see a Joe Google red wing boot in between two pancakes.
My point though, my point, dad, look at that.
But my point though,
that I'm not saying it doesn't look good.
I'm saying that that nobody goes to a store and says, I just, when,
when a waitress comes over and goes eight doll and she pulls a pencil out from
behind her ear and she goes, I guess she goes to write down. She goes,
I'll have a stack of pancakes. She goes show, would you like anything on that?
I never, no one goes, of course, ham and cheese.
Nobody says that to a regular traditional pancake.
The fact that you can be like, I have great crape.
The crepe is meant for something different than a traditional.
It's a thinner pancake. That's made slightly differently.
And if it doesn't count the need or does the Belgian waffle Joe's favorite
pancake,
a Belgian waffle sandwich quickie while we're regular waffles,
you need a Belgian waffle. No, your knocks it's too big. You can't do it.
I don't even want to say in your argument anymore,
you were bragging earlier about how you could make a Belgium.
You can make a waffle sandwich and you could never do that with a pancake.
And I said, yes, you can get rid of a crepe and you should crave some count.
You're going to make a Belgian waffle sandwich.
You're going to Belgian waffle show.
That would be ridiculous because they had this big,
but I would take a triangle of it. It over.
Slice of bread. Oh, okay.
Really? All right. Let's go to the polls. Really?
Wait, wait, hold on. Hold on, hold on. Let's just go.
So you know Joe's favorite pancakes are ham and cheese pancakes. No,
I didn't say that. Yeah. That's not what I said, Joe Love Joe.
Joe is one of my favorite pancakes is ham and cheese pancakes.
You said you love to put it on him. I didn't say that.
You said the words I love to put on him and used say that I love to have my
crazy. He said, I like, yes. Great. And say, what's my favorite pancake.
You said on our milk whipped butter and maple syrup pancake, bro. Okay.
Well what you said it isn't five inches thick. There you go.
But it's still just a waffle. You're putting still just a pancake.
It's a thin pancake times like these that I wish we had a third party. Holy.
You saw it on the internet with your own two eyes.
I'm craving ham and cheese pancakes all day at night. Can't wait. Can't wait.
I can't wait for it said it looked delicious.
When you saw the picture of it with the regular pig cake,
nobody says the phrase, I'm going to go get some ham and cheese pancakes.
Nobody says the phrase, get a Belgian waffle sandwich. Okay.
What we're doing here is a wasting time arguing points that don't make extra
matters is that waffles are taken to the polls.
Taking the polls. Let's see what we got here. Let's see what we got here.
Humble pie time. Humble pie time like this anymore.
You love it. What do we got?
Seven. [inaudible] sorry.
Bleak that we've done. It's 51 49. I can't do this.
We have to wait another couple of minutes till close to call
50.9%.
Pancakes takes waffles at
0.9%. Don't even say 51. What?
It is 0.9%. Let it staying the way it should.
Percent should show you that you have you're completely off the Mark.
I'm not off the Mark.
The goal isn't to be more on the Mark than not the goal is to win the debate I
wanted to bait. I'm right.
Pancakes. One, my food one.
Let's see what some comments are and we'll keep checking in.
What is that? It's two feet.
With jelly on them. It's really gross.
[inaudible] I'm saying you're the peanut butter. Joey roses is the jelly. Oh,
I see. It's a foot with peanut butter. Let me tell you something right now.
Let me tell you something right now. That's a nice way.
59, 51 49. You cannot, you cannot begin to gloat the way you're gloating.
Are you kidding? I mean, in, in five minutes, in five minutes,
this could be the other way. Could you, so don't close like that. Why?
And also by the way,
I think this is a win for me because pancakes is way,
way more popular. Pancakes are way more. They were the front runner.
They were the favorite to come this close under 1%.
Nobody did when cakes sip it around since 1430.
So the 15 hundreds got nothing to do with the way the show is still wrapped
around 440 years after the pancake.
And we are under a percentage sky Dalton.
I think it's a doll. I guess that's a man. I can't see the picture.
I don't know if that's a male or female name, but anyway, Dalton says,
talk about, speak in my language. Pancakes are they are Eggo.
Waffles. Almost my exact argument.
With my heart on the line. It all caps. Oh my God.
Someone just wrote option C French toast.
I know French toast enters the chat. I know about French toast.
That would have been a great three-way episode. Pancakes, waffles, French toast.
It would have been. Cause I got news for ya. We might rematch.
I got news for you. I think French toast is like a dark horse here.
I really think French toast is, is, is how did we not think of French toast?
I thought of it through out the entire argument.
I just decided not to bring it up. No, it's weird.
It's complicated enough already with this.
French crepe French toast, our French toast is just a pancake.
You pop in my head a few times. I didn't want to complicate things.
Because it was like, we were we're, you know, we're,
that's not what we were debating. And,
and it couldn't support either of our foods. You know what I mean?
This race is closer than Biden and Trump.
Waffles period, waffles, hands down, pancakes too. Fluffy enough for me,
depends.
And uh, fluffy, blueberry pancakes for breakfast,
but I do love good chicken and waffles for dinner. Wait, go back.
I need 24 hours. I need 24 hour prep.
If I'm going to have pancakes in the morning, waffles are a little easier.
Waffles are just pancakes with some actual texture and contrast great,
uh.
Homemade waffles, greater than pancakes, greater than frozen waffles.
I'd honestly take a frozen waffle over a fresh pancake any day. Look,
you heard it.
My argument about frozen waffles. I'll bang out a whole box of Eggos, right?
Yeah. He's someone, very reasonable. Waffles are more reliable,
but pancakes are better when done. Right?
You're a person that I can have a dialogue with, sir. Okay. Well.
I love how it's written to just you. Like,
it's just you here talking to yourself for an hour. Just pointing out a point.
It resonated with me. You don't have to gloat even more. By the way,
if we refresh right now, I may be a winner. All right. Refresh.
If you were frustrating now, but it made me be a winner. Oh my God.
It's less than a. Now it's 0.7%, babe.
The footsteps you hear him or do you hear the footsteps?
And pancakes was the front runner.
I know you're getting down to a half of a percentage of shame that we got to
come on base basis. Shame. We got to end the episode. This is one of them.
I feel like this is the stretch. And it's like, Hey,
comes waffled on the inside. I'll tell you what show. I bet you really.
Great asking for that extra hour of sleep right now because had we started an
hour earlier, we wouldn't be so pressed for time right now, would we?
And we have to end the episode.
Folks. Pancakes is the winner.
Who did he pick him and who is our great, uh, you gotta give me something.
I'll give it to scroll down. Mike. I want to give it to this.
Person right here because it's so close to what you said. I'm gonna just say it.
I hate pancakes. I will not eat pancakes.
It's like eating a syrup covered sponge. That's so close to what you said.
We got to give it to them.
That goes to, to, to Shelly. Think it's pronounced at real Moses tweets.
You can follow Shelly at real Moses tweet, uh, come by the Joey Rosa sandwich.
Shop 12 to four, Wednesday to Friday at the stand in New York city. Uh,
Joe Rosa comedy on Instagram and Twitter. Yes, that's it. I love it.
I hope you guys have been enjoying the taste buds pod.
We are toying with the idea of doing a live streaming episode on YouTube where
you guys can have this entire conversation with us in the moment. Uh,
if so we will let you know when that's going to be, uh,
we think it's going to be a blast.
So it's something that we're really looking forward to. What else?
Just go to the YouTube is no pressure network on YouTube. That's a channel.
We can find a, Hey babe, the other podcast. And uh, yeah,
we appreciate you guys and we're having fun. And uh,
if you liked this podcast through the, I always hear this too.
And we never say it, but like, if you like it,
the best thing that I think you could do for us is to share it and rate it,
right?
Like on any anywhere you're watching or listening to it or wherever you could
share it and rate it, subscribe, all those things that really, really,
really helps us. That's like the most immediate way.
If you're a fan that you would show us some reviews on iTunes, please,
we're trying to build it up. We're having a blast doing this. No, it doesn't.
It doesn't look like it, but it's fun. We like, we like arguing this stuff.
It's great. So thank you guys. Uh, am I forgetting anything? Oh,
that's it right on. Yeah, we'll see you next time. They still love me. Oh wait.
I forgot. I'm sorry. Yes,
because he is refresh refresh right now that are fresh right now.
Have you, do you still love me? I still love you. Refresh. I still love you.
Waffles are up by 0.1% 50.1 to 49.9.
Oh my God. Oh my God. That's gotta shake up for debate.
It's gotta be a rematch. It's gotta be a rematch.
You can't walk away with this with your head held high. It's got favorites,
got a sting that the polls closed. It's got a sting does its thing.
You should also stay knew.
I walked away the Victor I'll read in your heart of hearts. Oh.
Cause you know what? The real winner I'll rematch you all day long.
You think cause you, you think maybe we do the rematch live.
This is very cool because you took a 0.1% lead that I'm going to be shaking in
my boots right now. I think you should be.
I think the tightest turn and you seeing that the syrup is flowing total waffled
apartment. I think that we've already right now.
You're I think right now you're actually like actually you're you're cloaking.
What you're really feeling inside, which is your shook.
We've already agreed that in a less than 5%, um, uh,
margin, we would consider rematch rematch. I'm a hundred percent,
but this is 8.1. No, it's that? This is what everyone
filed. I think. All right. Well I appreciate you waffle people.
You come in a little bit late to the party, but I appreciate it. Uh,
I'm going to go to bed tonight, feeling that waffles one.
This I'm going to go to bed tonight,
feeling that the rematch is going to be taken by waffles. Uh,
I feel good about what I put up. I still love you to taste buds.
They come into the mic.
Talking about the food. They hate talking about the food they like to.
Fool's gonna fake it. Only one food, 10 rate taste buds, man,
nearly coming to them. I can talk and say taste good.
If you don't want your purse, they'll take your pay stub taste.